all right guys
bang bang i have a treat for you today
i've got ryan sulcus he decided to sit
down
like a psychopath and write a 120 page
report
all about bitcoin ether crypto and god
knows what else is in this thing
so he's here to talk about it thank you
so much for uh doing this man
you know it's been a couple years since
we last caught up back when you were a
wee lad
we did one of the early podcasts uh and
it's uh it's it's good to uh to do this
again
absolutely i was actually at the nader
last time right so we're like now we're
moving on up in the world because i
think we caught up around 4 000
like the worst part of the bear market
in 2018 and now we're back on top
absolutely let's start just with a quick
overview of
uh your background and what massari does
sure um so i've been in the industry for
about seven and a half years
almost exclusively on the information
side of things
so as an independent research analyst
then
as a seed investor digital currency
group one of those prolific investors in
space
dcg is structured as a holding company
so we acquired coin desk in 2016. i let
that restructuring
uh for about 18 months got the business
to profitability and ran the consensus
conference franchise which some of your
listeners may have attended
uh and then in late 2017 early 2018 i
started
uh masari and back then this was
basically the height of the last bull
market
and uh our thesis uh my co-founder dan
and i our thesis
was this ico boom is a load of crap
but there's a kernel of really
interesting uh tokens and
and really interesting assets that we
think are going to be big in a decade
um so let's build a company that's going
to
uh yes satisfy the shorthand for
bloomberg of crypto
assuming that this does become a
bonafide asset class and it's not just
about bitcoin
ether and then all these also runs that
ultimately wash out in the next cycle
and of course that happened right the
the market corrected a lot of the you
know crappy projects you know went to
zero
but the teams that kept building uh sure
enough were
you know more often than not able to uh
find product market fit maybe
with different applications not
necessarily the assets but that
ultimately led to with some innovations
around okay how can we
decentralize the economics of this
killer app that we've built
and actually create you know uh
financial uh economics around it
uh so that it's interesting and
compelling to actually own a stake in
these decentralized networks and that's
basically the concept of these
decentralized finance assets that we'll
talk about a little bit and uh some of
the
web
3 tokens and what are now called
non-fungible tokens
but if you add it all up you know we've
basically got this explosion
of interesting uh financial assets
that didn't exist um three years ago
right bitcoin's 12 years old but many of
these assets
uh beyond bitcoin uh just simply did not
exist as
even as early as recently as three years
ago which is when we started the company
and so um our starting point was to
build out a research library that was
focused on
disclosures and more qualitative
information right um
you know models are only useful as their
inputs right so
so getting quantum quantitative data out
of these projects and trying to make
models or trying to make sense of
whether they're going to be at all
interesting was was a fool's errand
and instead we focused on things like
okay who are the stakeholders what are
the proposed economics and design of the
system and kind of the use cases of
of these protocols and maybe you know
guess their assets as well
um what um you know if they got a
security audience if they
you know or they had adequately
represented by council where they
located you know all the things
that would essentially be in a
prospectus um outside of the financial
statement
uh so we aggregated all that we've
worked with close to 100 teams now
on the project side and on the
enterprise side we work with
dozens of the top exchanges custodians
investment funds
on a subscription research product that
looks like the
bloomberg terminal that um and then a
corporate actions alerts and monitoring
system called intel
that basically helps people come up uh
and stay up to date on all these
non-quantitative updates uh they're
happening
whether it's you know governance uh
proposals
hard forks security issues uh software
releases alike
um so it's a pretty comprehensive
enterprise suite that's uh that's built
right now for crypto professionals
crypto funds
uh and enterprise companies um
but uh ultimately we think of the next
cycle you know gonna obviously be a
massive uh customer set for us
so you rate this report i think this is
year four
that you wrote this report uh literally
it is 120 pages which
uh most people would say that is absurd
why do you need 120 pages
uh i've read almost all of it uh i sat
down i thought it was gonna be like 20
pages and realized 120 takes a little
bit longer
um and i thought it was actually really
concise
in terms of it just covers so much
material um and so maybe just talk
through like why write the report why
sit down i think you actually wrote it
like it's like you like hired an outside
team to do it but why sit down and write
this
well i mean first of all i have a couple
of advantages right one i've
i've written prolifically for a long
time so it's a little bit faster for me
to do
uh second of all uh our team produces
so much terrific content on a day-to-day
basis through our pro product that i was
able to you know not only absorb that
over the course of the year
but and really stay up to speed on
things but also borrow
um some of their graphics some of you
know they're they're kind of
you know better witticisms you know
throughout the report um
so it's all original and um
you know i did spend some time doing it
but uh you know you stand on the
shoulders of giants you know so to speak
uh first of all and second of all i
i think about this report as kind of our
guiding document for the year ahead so
it kind of doubles as a strategy session
for where
you know we're thinking about the
industry we're thinking about taking the
company in your head
and to your point um
it is shockingly i i think concise right
and i even call that out in the
introduction
you look at something like this and i
think you you'd expect you know drivel
and filler and
you know uh words for the sake of words
but the truth of the matter is it's
broken up into 12 sections there's a
section on bitcoin there's a section on
ethereum there's a section on
decentralized finance there's a section
on infrastructure trends
um so they're all kind of like you know
10 page reports and augmented together
uh into this kind of giant year-end
piece and
um that's more of a function for just
how fast the industry's growing right
when i when i first
wrote the original it was i think
january
first or second you know 2018 and it was
literally a medium post
right uh and then the next year uh one
of my friends in the
industry is uh now an investor at
paradigm uh
arjun uh actually shotgun me and he
wrote his
a few days before i was supposed to
publish mine and his was so much better
than what i was going to publish
so he just like totally ate my lunch and
uh and i was i was
i was so you know uh crestfallen about
it and just like you know i just waste
so much time
but um it kind of led to actually
creating this as a year-to-year
repetitive product that we were
gonna put out um because you know we
kind of find it so valuable
not only in you know framing our own
product roadmap but
helping people come up to speed on
what's going on
you know the problem i think is it's um
with with information businesses in
general in the industry
you always have to keep in mind that
there's someone starting at home plate
right you know we're like rounding
second
you know the industry is is still early
um
so i don't think anyone's rounding third
or kind of close to the finish line here
nor will they ever be but um it's it's
even more challenging as more complexity
gets added on as more
sectors get added on to remember that
like
and you you have done a masterful job at
this remember that people
are like getting out of the batter's box
and they're asking like okay what's
bitcoin
like they've heard of it now i think
right you know most people
can can give you maybe a one or two
liner but they haven't studied it right
so
when that's your starting point and then
you try to get into
well you know there was some hacks this
year that weren't really hacks but they
were basically just combinations of
these you know
exploits of oracle infrastructure using
flash loans people are like what the
[ __ ] are you talking about
so um you know we we try our best to
to put it in plain english for folks
that are trying to come up to speed
absolutely so we're gonna go through a
couple of the topics that are in the
piece but i highly recommend everyone go
actually read it uh the first is uh
let's start with the king
bitcoin uh you basically give a bitcoin
outlook for 2021.
um how do you kind of synthesize that
down
uh in terms of what do you think happens
next year
yeah i look i think that the the bull
and bear case
uh just the cliff notes you know we
tried to lay out pretty
pretty clearly right it's it's become a
macro
narrative story for most investors and
the easiest way to think about bitcoin
is as digital gold i think that
narrative fits
it works it's not perfect but it's it's
pretty good and that's the one that the
institutional investors have really
rallied around
um beyond that um and beyond kind of the
macro environment where there's
you know unprecedented levels of
negative yield
yielding debt and unprecedented levels
of
money printing and debt modernization
you've also got the fact that smart
money investors knew about bitcoin back
in 2017 they saw the spike it was very
very public it was very loud
and then it died in 2018 and now it's
resurged all the way back
and i think a lot of them have
appreciation for things
that don't die when when they really
should because it makes you take a step
back and actually think what did i miss
the first time around
um you know yes it was probably too
early to invest in 2017 but now there's
three years more infrastructure there's
three years more
of a lindy effect around this asset
because uh it does
it has proven staying power not just for
me and my experience looking at it from
2017 but has done this in 2011 2013 2017
and now again today so i think um from a
bowl standpoint uh first of all you know
most investors are copycats
so there's a lot of really good
investors many some some of whom you
know
you've had on your podcast that have
made it
safe for people in institutional
investments
to actually make an allocation here and
remember you know these aren't people
betting the farm it's you know
one half a percent one percent maybe
maybe a couple percentage points
um and and i would uh say that you know
when uh when druckenmiller
and bill miller and and uh ralph powell
and some of these others
that are widely followed in financial
circles um
talk about making significant
investments in bitcoin it has the same
impact that mark andreessen and fred
wilson had
on the venture capital side back in
2013.
um and that's obviously pretty powerful
now and i think
we'll probably you know end here or talk
a little bit more about this later but
um the bear case is because it's so big
now and because you've got all these
high-profile people talking about it
uh as a macro hedge it's on everybody's
radar in dc it's on everybody's radar in
beijing and kind of everywhere in
between
so um there's gonna be a lot of
questions this year over
um the true essence of bitcoin and
crypto and
and kind of how it fits uh how do you
reconcile
the uh truly peer-to-peer unregulated
kind of wild west aspects of it
um to the reality that for the most part
this next rally is is actually finally
going to be led by
institutions and you know heavily
regulated entities
and so when you think through that um
there's kind of three key pieces that
you talked about in the piece so one is
uh this grayscale etf two is coinbase
going public
and then three is kind of fatfa or uh
privacy type
concerns uh let's start with grayscale's
etf
uh those that are listening may say wait
a second grayscale doesn't have an etf
grayscale has a truss
structure talk through why do you refer
to the etf
so i call them side door etfs uh and
this is a
uh basically a function of the sec's
unwillingness to approve an etf
based on their sense that price
discovery is is
you know really taking place in the east
versus in
properly surveilled markets in the west
um
and what grayscale was able to do and
and and kind of very cleverly
took advantage of early on uh was uh
rule 144
sales of restricted securities so
basically you could have this private
trust as a close-end vehicle um people
could invest in it at a daily
nav just like you would in an etf
but they'd ultimately be restricted for
12 months
now it's down to six months for a couple
of grey scales
trusts but 12 months for the rest of the
family six months for bitcoin
um and essentially they
uh because of that dynamic have a
massive premium
on the public gbtc
shares that are unrestricted versus what
investors have been able to capitalize
on
um going directly to greyscale you know
based on their accreditation
um and what has really you know uh kind
of put this uh
in hyperdrive is the emergence of credit
markets
and um the ability for people to
actually create
shares in grayscale on credit
you know just just you know having in
some cases they can pledge the
the grayscale shares as the underlying
collateral in that case you're basically
just
clipping coupons on premium um which is
the spread between what you'll get in
six months
you know typically that's around 20 to
30 for bitcoin uh
in the gbtc shares uh it's up to 60
now for the ethereum trust um
between you know what the underlying
spot value is
and uh and what the public unrestricted
uh share prices
and what that's really a function of is
the fact that you can't um
the the redemption process is extremely
inefficient
versus an etf which where this process
would happen daily
now it's constrained by the six-month
lock-up so you've got a significant
supply demand and balance
in public markets um i i think the most
surprising thing
uh maybe for many people is that this
premium has not gone away and
in some cases it's it's stayed very high
over time
and in fact you'd expect this to
actually trade at a discount because
grayscale takes two percent fee
per year um that hasn't been the case
and for as long as it's not the case you
know grayscale is going to ramp
considerably
and it's going to be a hell of a trade
for institutional investors that are
getting into the industry
it looks like free money to them um
in many cases because they can they can
do this with with leverage so
uh i'd say that is a has been a major
you know driving factor and in fact
grayscale has acquired
um you know a significant chunk of the
bitcoin that's been mined this year
if you look at it that way yeah i think
they own something like around 2.5
of uh of the circulating supply of
bitcoin from what i've read
let's talk a little bit about coinbase
uh different business but obviously
still a piece of infrastructure
uh they have plans to go public it
sounds like based on uh kind of public
media reports
um what's the importance of that or the
significance
well coinbase is is kind of the og in
the western markets
um they were they have been the highest
profile brand i'd argue in
in crypto um basically since day one or
at least
you know since it came into the public
consciousness in 2013
um and um what they what coinbase has
done
uh phenomenally well uh kind of ties
back to an early decision they made to
not
throw the baby out with the bathwater
once other competitors emerged
and that is keeping their one percent
fee as a retail brokerage
versus trying to immediately respond to
lower fee
competitors that followed soon after
right so if you remember circle
um circle basically came out with a
competitive product to coinbase
called 2014 and they said you know we're
not going to charge a one percent fee
it's going to be
you know zero fee uh trading to to
enter and exit these these bitcoin
positions and then they would just kind
of make money on the spread or around
the otc desk on the back end
um coinbase never did that and they so
they have basically bifurcated their
product
between the retail front end that that
kind of first time buyer
knows and uses which also includes a
very
rock-solid custody product by extension
and so it's kind of like the one place
that most investors can go
buy their bitcoin forget about it and
keep it safe
and then at the same time they have
coinbase pro which is one more liquid
exchanges
um a much more competitive business much
tighter fees much tighter spreads
you know that kind of a traditional
trading set can can actually leverage
but um i would say um
what has really separated coinbase is
their approach to
um to regulators in the us and
europe in particular and how thoughtful
they've been
in that multi-year process of getting
regulators comfortable with their
business
um and then uh it's kind of the the
just the blue chip brand that they have
for security and and
uh and and safety right um
for newcomers into the space that want
price exposure
don't necessarily you know want to
actually play around with some of the
more exotic applications
got it and then all this leads to kind
of a positive sentiment there's lots of
kind of
big um infrastructure being built there
all the trends are pointing in the right
direction
and then we get to something like fat fa
and these privacy
type concerns explain those
so the um financial action task force
uh i don't know if it's fat for fat f uh
i've always
said fat f that might be wrong i'll ask
the queen center guys um
but um but the the gist is
that any regulated money transmitter
needs to know their customer and they
need to abide by certain
anti-money laundering provisions and
basically the same things that other you
know regulated financial players you
know have to abide by um
crypto introduces some unique challenges
with something called the travel rule
where um the fataf standards have gotten
more onerous and and potentially more
restrictive
on exchanges exchange's ability to
allow their customers to send crypto
to wherever they may choose um
so it's one thing to know kind of the
source of funds and to file these
reports uh it's quite another to
actually actively block
exchanges and other regulated entities
from allowing
you or i to move money from our coinbase
wallet
into a self-custodian wallet like a
hardware wallet
or to send it to a smart contract or to
send it
peer-to-peer to someone that is not
necessarily known and basically fat f
um regulations would uh would require
that there's
some um knowledge or some tracking
of who those funds are actually getting
sent to if you take this to the extreme
what that could mean is that there's a
gradual march
towards outlawing self-custody and
truly encrypted private peer-to-peer
cash-like
transfers this is important because
at the end of the day uh bitcoin is
supposed to be this large
interoperable network um not just about
kind of the anarchist roots but but
even if you just think about it uh from
a tech standpoint it's supposed to be
this interoperable
global standard and the second that you
start introducing
some of these extra requirements or
restrictions in the worst case
um you can break the fungibility of the
asset itself which basically means that
you've
you've bifurcated the network into like
clean coins and derby coins
even if they're not actually dirty right
just like these are the the white list
of coins
and and these are ultimately the bad
coins um
and so this has been a concern for a
while and it's one of the reasons that
um
that maybe the most important core
developments uh that are being worked on
uh by the bitcoin you know uh community
are around privacy and and how to make
it
less likely that uh we'll have this
two-tiered system where
coins can be tainted just because
they've uh originated from a certain
source yeah and what's so interesting to
me about this is like
there's always the fear and kind of the
fud if you will that everyone talks
about
versus what's actually going on um
sometimes it's literally nothing's going
on but everyone fears something
sometimes
uh there's a lot going on and nobody
fears it this kind of feels like it's
actually somewhere in between that is
somewhat rational in terms of something
to pay attention to
um we're gonna talk about ether and
ethereum
uh that is probably the most
controversial thing that comes up on
this podcast
uh you just start wherever you want uh
there's a big section in the uh in the
report on it
kind of how do you look at that asset
and that network uh
in terms of where it's grown to today
and then how do you look about it
going into 2021 well first of all have
you been red pilled yet
what's your current style i'm not sure
where you are in your evolution on
ethereum so i don't know if i need to
red pill you
or or like where we're standing today so
like let me let me hear from you first
and then we'll
we'll we'll talk at that level listen i
i
hold no ether uh we can talk about why
that is
we have it invested in a number of
businesses that
uh build on top of the ethereum network
uh for a variety of different things
we also have invested in a number of
defy companies that are building on top
of bitcoin instead of ether
or ethereum uh and then obviously
everyone knows that i've been super
bullish about uh digital art and kind of
uh how that's playing out and so i
always put myself in like everyone wants
to like label me some maximalist and all
stuff like
i'm actually just like pretty rational
uh and the
concerns that i have um usually aren't
things that
people think are ridiculous and also
when they think about from a portfolio
construction standpoint
uh i usually lay out an argument that
makes the people who hold ether look
good uh which is unique uh but i don't
hold any myself
and uh and so we can get into all that
but that's kind of where i am is don't
hold any ether but uh uh have kind of
done probably more than most of the
trolls on twitter in terms of
uh you know doing things around the
ethereum network uh just you know we'll
see how it plays out
so uh the one thing i will say is i
think you have time right uh
and i'll get into why that is in a
second but i do think that uh
ether is probably the only other assets
that you you probably need to hold as a
crypto investor
if you're thinking about making a
long-term bet on the industry
um there's a few reasons for this one um
bitcoin has absolutely won uh
hands down when it comes to just the the
virality
of the asset the the you know bitcoin is
a shelling point
is a a new form of digital gold
but um they are uh getting
further and further behind the network
is getting further and further behind
in terms of being useful for additional
applications
there is some that's going on i know i
know you've invested in companies that
that are
kind of working on this but uh in my
eyes ethereum has become the settlement
layer
for all crypto applications not named
store value bitcoin right um you
have seen this with the explosion of
stable coins uh and
the close to a trillion dollars in
volume that will be processed on
ethereum which is
actually more than bitcoin this year um
you've seen this with the explosion of
applications
again almost all of which should have
any meaningful value
um and volume are sitting on top of
ethereum
it has i think at least in order
probably orders of magnitude
advantage when it comes to human capital
and developer mind share
and the the clincher and this is why i
say you have time
is that ethereum is going to be
probably more risky than bitcoin for
the next couple of years because it's
got this very convoluted network upgrade
that that you know
the entire ecosystem you need to get
they just got through the first
milestone which is which is important
um but after
uh if ether if ethereum
is able to make it through this upgrade
called ethereum 2.0
it will arguably
be less risky than bitcoin is in terms
of its security assumption
assumptions right so that's a loaded uh
issue that we we can get into but
what ethereum really needs to de-risk is
whether
its network is secure at scale using
this consensus mechanism called proof of
stake
the reason that they may have an
advantage is they have a perpetual
issuance model that bitcoiners hate
because it's unclear whether there will
be a fixed supply in the future
but it's very very low and you might
argue
that it is better to have one percent
inflation
in a protocol like this just to
serve as as rewards for the
maintainers of that network the
validators net network
whereas in a couple of years bitcoin is
going to drop well below one percent and
it's very unclear at this point
um whether the fee market in bitcoin is
going to be sufficient
to actually you know protect
transactions in addition
you know you've got the issue that uh 70
of hashing capacity and a good chunk of
the network's power is actually being
you know driven out of
uh out of china which uh we we could
have a
full episode conversation i know you've
probably had better guesses on that can
can talk to the the pros and cons of
that but it's um
it's probably less of a technical issue
it's more of a geopolitical issue at
this point
um and i think ethereum gets away from
that so um
those are are kind of the basics but i
will call out
that there's um there's maybe a little
bit of like a tail wagging the dog
element here as well i think in 2021
professional like institutional
investors are going to look at the
grayscale
eth product and they're going to look at
that premium
and they're going to salivate and
they're going to say you know what
maybe i don't love this versus bitcoin
but this seems like a pretty good
risk adjusted return for my money for
holding six months
if this premium can stay anywhere close
to what it is so if ethereum just trades
in its consistent you know historical
range with bitcoin
then um you know you should be able to
you know print premium uh over the
course of
a couple consecutive you know six month
period so that's netting out the impacts
of you know taxes and everything like
that
but you combine all those things and um
and you're able to pull through some
demand on the institutional side
which you know can can kick-start an
institutional narrative to begin with
and i think over the course the next
couple years that could
basically have ethereum in the
conversation credibly
very seriously um as um as
an alternative to bitcoin i'm not saying
that my portfolio is balanced that way
either
but i do what do you have what was your
portfolio construction
so my portfolio is uh probably 70
bitcoin uh at this point about 10 z cash
and then 20 split between ethereum and
uh decentralized finance applications i
tend to invest more on the defy
applications because they are
producing real network fees at this
point
and my sense is that if ethereum does
well it's because d5 is doing well so
i'd rather take the higher beta
but i think if i were to to move money
it would not be from d5 to either
probably be from bitcoin to
ethereum over time uh just getting into
that balance i'm probably slightly
underweight
ethereum versus you know where i would
be if i was just looking at the market
cap weightings
all right hold on time to come so here's
my
general uh sense of all of this right
is there's two different stories i think
you see the same way kind of
what i've heard you see say and also uh
write
which is the argument that bitcoin is
money and store value and one day can
grow into a medium of exchange and
stable value et cetera
i think you're right it's like that
pretty much has taken hold
both from a uh data standpoint and kind
of the metrics of the market but
also too that narrative is uh maybe not
completely uh embraced by the
institutional world but definitely
getting there right when you see um you
know stanley druckenmiller or paul tudor
jones or
uh you know not jp morgan city all these
people are talking about it in terms of
hey it's a settlement network uh similar
to a paypal venmo whatever
what i think the biggest turn off to me
has always been
is you know there's the whole d5 crowd
running around saying etha's money for
example and so when i was reading your
report
you specifically have a section that
says eth is not money
uh so we can talk about that in a second
but i think part of
what we're starting to see is
there is activity for sure the question
is
how much of the activity is innovation
versus
just continued repurposing of the ico
nonsense
and kind of all that and i think
actually like there's a mixture right
it's not 100 all innovation it's not 100
all kind of
the nonsense either um and one of the
areas
that to me like just blew me away when i
saw what was happening in terms of
people yelling and screaming saying like
eath is going to take over the world was
with all the yield farming stuff
like when you really look at like what
was happening right is basically people
were creating tokens and they were just
dumping those tokens on
uh retail investors and some were like
outright i
am like kind of rug pull on you um but
very very different uh models and so for
me it was like
it's almost like developers learned
about financial engineering like that
like essentially what was going on right
and that's not to say it's a bad thing
like there's a lot of financial
engineering that goes on the traditional
uh markets that um you know it's very
valuable for all kinds of reasons but i
think that the reason why i bring that
up
is bitcoin is telling a monetary story
it's telling a store of value a money
story a macro economic story
that tends to be very clear concise
and either you believe it or you don't
right and so if you're an institutional
investor
here's the argument here's what's going
on with the macro environment either you
think this is going to happen or not
two three years ago nobody thought it
now i think it's it's going from kind of
a contrarian trade to a consensus trade
but ethan is telling a different story
he's not telling a monetary store it's
telling an innovation story
right so basically it looks much more
like a early stage technology investment
and when you get into that innovation
story the part to me that
i think people are confusing right
is there's really three groups of
individuals or
organizations that are going to look at
the asset so you got retail right
plenty of retail investors on bitcoin
plenty on eth and
plenty own the long tail of whatever
else is in there right
then you've got what i'll call traders
these can be both wall street and kind
of traditional traders or the crypto
traders
things like that arbitrage trade uh with
the eth the grayscale fun
uh trust they're gonna exploit whatever
they can right it's kind of numbers on
the screen to them they actually don't
really care a lot of times like what the
underlying asset is they just want to
make money they're pure capitalist and
they're trading on a screen
the there's a third group though which
is what i'll put call investors they're
not traders and they're not retail and
they're looking much more long term
i think that the the obstacle that is in
front of ethereum and eth
which doesn't mean that you can't
overcome the obstacle it's just a much
bigger obstacle than let's say the
bitcoin community has at this point
is you basically have to tell a story
that is we're going to
decentralize and disrupt the entire
financial system
and five years ago nobody believed that
right like d5 wasn't even really a part
of the conversation like it was all
about you know his capital formation and
icos and all that there's now some
people who believe that right and
whether it's venture capitalists or even
some people on wall street that
are starting to believe that but i think
that where
we don't know yet is there's still a
whole bucket of unknowns and
uncertainties
around what does that world look like
right and is it literally
you know and i say this in a loving
positive way but is it literally 20 year
olds right
who create decentralized applications
and then throw it out in the world and
there's like hey whatever happens
happens
like some people are like that's awesome
that like long innovation and
let's go disrupt the world other people
like that is the scariest thing i've
ever heard in my life
right and and so i think that that's the
part where
uh there's just a big disconnect between
like what's happening and all the
activity
and really like how what i'll call
critical professional investors are
viewing the space
and see i think what you're arguing and
this is where i'll shut up and you and
you can kind of explain
is if those uncertainties or unknowns
get more clarity then that's where
there's like this great wall of money
almost that you think will kind of flow
into the space and people will have much
more comfort
similar to what kind of has happened to
bitcoin over the last i don't know three
four years
that basically potentially could happen
with eth
but there's some work to be done before
that is that generally accurate or am i
way off well i i i think it's accurate
um but you know i think you answered
your own question
in some cases you know ethereum uh went
live as a
as a network just ethereum the smart
contract platform
uh about five and a half years ago now
versus 12
for bitcoin and let's give you know
bitcoin let's say ethereum should be a
little bit accelerated because it has
the benefit of kind of you know riding
off of bitcoin's you know coattails and
in terms of
you know red pilling people with the
concept that a network like this could
exist
um it's still only been you know five
and a half years from
the very very basic network launch and
only a few years
since some of the application providers
really had the infrastructure
upon which uh to even start building
right
so um i do want to talk about yield
farming in particular because
i think it highlights the difference
between the ico
euphoria of 2017 which
we thought was [ __ ] to be like right
out of the gates we wrote about it
and still we built a company uh knowing
that we might cater to assets like that
in the future because some of them would
stick
90 of them would wash out 10 of them
would stick
um the difference with defy uh
yield farming and with the ico boom in
2017
is is the ice like that was just
unregistered securities
issuance by and large right
i don't care what should like what your
white paper said you know like
some of the worst and most offensive you
know frauds during the time that
will never get prosecuted because they
raise so much money and they can just
hire the right lawyers
to help them get away with it just like
the banks
they literally had in their token sale
documents
there is no utility uh never will be
any use or you know any reason to
invest nor is this even an investment
you're literally just purchasing a funny
money token that that's
never going to do anything everything
they booked
and they booked it as revenue in some
cases they raised billions of dollars in
the process um and everybody took those
sales like wink wink nudge nudge you
know
they have to write this because the sec
is watching
but uh in fact what was still being done
was you're raising money
you know with people hoping to get rich
um
and now i don't feel bad for most people
that piled in because
no one cared about the tech they were
investing in no one was thinking about
like a long-term investor
just like who like who's gonna be the
greater fool on the other side of my
investment
right okay so that was 2017. um the
difference now is
most of the networks that launched this
year or sorry
that introduced tokens this year have
been working have been functioning for a
couple of years now
and they've seen their volumes spike
significantly talking about
decentralized exchange i'm talking about
some of the lending protocols in
particular
and that's important right because these
worked before they introduced the
concept of these governance tokens
necessarily
what yield farming did was it
essentially introduced
tokens as an incentive for people to
participate more actively in these
networks
for decentralized exchange that means
actually becoming a market maker
right and the market makers can make
money just like you would in kind of
traditional
financial markets slightly different
design because you're talking about
smart contracts but basically
the market makers can get can make money
how do you solve this cold start problem
and encourage more of them to make money
well you give them this token in
addition to the fees that they're going
to earn
by staking assets and making these
markets
and those will constitute ownership
interests
in this globally decentralized network
and they'll be able to control it and by
the way part of that
governance and control is going to be
their ability to set protocol fees
long term which will accrue to them so
there is a cash flow component here
almost like investing in you know if you
were able to invest in a decentralized
facebook
from day one and facebook had gradually
gone public with a data token that said
every single user that we onboard every
single ad dollar that we make we're kind
of gradually we're going to give you the
early users
more of these tokens because you're
valuable in helping us bootstrap this
network you're helping us create gravity
to this system
and ultimately you're going to help us
scale to into a really big business so
you can price them
you know like using traditional
methodologies
lending was the same thing uh you know
when compound issued their token
they were already scaling and doing very
well
the issue was most people didn't want to
pick up pennies in front of a
steamroller
by lending money out through this smart
contract platform
for a marginal return still better than
the legacy markets but
you know is it worth the risk because
there's all this idiosyncratic
you know risk of ethereum and the
individual you know lending protocol
um and so the the token was a way to
kind of pull forward demand again
and essentially decentralize the
ownership of that
cash producing network utility but
i mean that's a that's a big big change
but i don't know the answer to this
but then that's what i'm asking uh my
understanding is that compound
worked perfectly fine without the token
it it did but it was going to scale very
slowly
right because you're talking about okay
how can we get people to um
contribute uh and and lend in this
peer-to-peer marketplace that has
all of these other extracurricular risks
when they're gonna get like four percent
that's why you know i say
it's like picking pennies up in front of
a steamroller these
these d5 tokens were sweeteners and they
were methods of
arguably protecting networks long term
because
all of these software developers that
created them initially
as those networks got bigger and bigger
i think we're going to run into more
regulatory risks
right like what is your actual control
here and and so you need to actually
provably you know get these things
decentralized
just from uh just basically to protect
their network uh
integrity um so you know i'd say
for for a subclass of like market
leaders that
already had useful working products that
were scaling
that the unit economics made sense those
tokens
also made sense now were there a bunch
of like [ __ ] projects that got
layered on in august and september when
you know the hype was going nuts of
course
um and that was no different from from
the icos right the ethereum ico
very interesting you know in hindsight
um
you know some of the the file coin um
sale very interesting arguably in
hindsight because
you can actually back into okay what are
the platform economics of these things
and
because they were kind of first to
market you knew that the teams were
actually thinking about these in a way
that um they were trying to align
incentives long term and actually scale
these networks
not just get rich quick which is what
all the kind of fast followers have done
yeah and i think part of the detractor
argument right is like compounds a great
example where
really the token was pure financial
engineering
right is hey we're going to create this
token then we're going to try to give it
to users to
drastically increase the financial
return they get so that incentivizes
more people to
uh come on to the system and again
i'm not going to debate whether that's
good bad whatever it's just financial
engineering and when people hear me say
financial engineering they're going to
think of it
from a negative connotation but again
almost every single thing in the
traditional market has some level of
financial engineering to it right so
it's just
that is what occurs in in financial
markets
i think the part that um there's a
spectrum
right and this is where uh i think the
debate really happens with the
or the controversial uh conversations is
like that spectrum of what it is
being told to investors or holders of
those tokens so there's some people who
are like
very egregious uh literally they don't
need the token whatsoever
and they use they sell it in order to
get revenue and that's basically how
they survive
right and i think that there's like very
very egregious people there and then all
the other on the other side of the
spectrum
is people who say like hey like this was
working and
we just used it in a very light way uh
and like we were super transparent about
what we were doing and like maybe there
was some kind of vote and everyone
agreed that we should do it
and that's what we're doing and i think
that like again
there are people who fall all along that
spectrum there's some people who think
that the most egregious thing is
actually fine
and there's some people who think the
lightest thing is like you know
basically a crime right or
shouldn't have happened and so i think
part of this whole
i don't know uh kind of complexity of
the industry
is nobody yet knows where we'll be 10
years from now
right and so it's almost like that's how
the market gets made in terms of
there are people literally betting
millions tens of millions hundreds of
millions billions
you know in some cases tens of billions
of dollars on some of these networks
playing out and some of them not playing
out
and that's where you get the vitriol
that's where you get the debate
that's where you get kind of all of this
stuff uh and to your point like
in 2017 when all the ico stuff was going
on like
i mean there wasn't a ton of people
saying it but there was definitely some
people being saying hey look icos are
stupid like you shouldn't do this
and 90 went to zero and people lost a
lot of money
and so i tend to think that like the
market will just figure it out
but the one thing i want to kind of
bring up is i also think that the
things that people are optimizing for
when they're in like what i'll call like
the weeds of defy
yield farming for example they're
optimizing something completely
different
than maybe the average like bitcoin
investor
right and so what i don't know is and
it's i don't actually think it's
possible
i don't think that we can kind of paint
an entire industry with like a broad
stroke
of hey there's one size fits all as to
what everyone should do
because everyone's optimizing for
something that's different
right and so where that ends up playing
out is there's returns that are driven
where people build like somebody may
actually build default applications on
ether or
ethereum and somebody may go build the
same thing on bitcoin and then like the
market will decide who wins
right so that's why like when it comes
to the debate stuff i'm just like like
the market will decide right
like i have my own personal opinions but
like if the market is the ultimate
referee or judge
then you actually want everyone trying
as many things as possible
and then like the thing that wins is
that much better because it basically
built all it beat all the other
competition right
yeah i mean the question is uh are you
hedging and and where are you
right like some of these uh indices
are toxic waste that just have like
straight market cap rankings
down you know uh marking up what
weighted rankings down the top 10 or top
50 or top 100
like that's just throwing money away um
but the question is you know where
should you
be diversifying if you want exposure
this this emerging asset class and my
argument i actually more or less agree
with you that
um there's bitcoin which is an asset and
then there's ethereum which
is basically the leading force in the
decentralized finance platform play
and then everything else is just kind of
you know picking horses no different
than picking
infrastructure winners you know that
have catered to the bitcoin
industry for for years right the
exchanges custodians
my my general sense is that you need
uh some exposure to ethereum or its
applications
somewhere across that value stack um in
addition to bitcoin because
you know there there still is a chance
that that bitcoin
uh or crypto wins but bitcoin for
whatever reason
has um has a flaw that prevents it from
from winning at scale
yeah and this is the age-old like
diversification versus concentration
right
and uh people will all make their own uh
their own
decisions from that i do think that the
the one thing that
uh will be very interesting to see
actually i would love your opinion on
this because we're talking about d5
uh my argument the entire time has been
like i don't know
90 95 of these things aren't
decentralized
like if the government says i'll shut it
down or you go to jail
there might be one or two right or five
or whatever it is that can't be shut
down
but majority of them can be shut down
and so here's the thing they
they can't here's the thing the teams
that are that spawn them
could be shut down right they could
basically be you know pencils down on
the project
you know we're done here the u.s
government
knocked on our door and we're gonna
divest and whatever um
but one of the beautiful things about
the industry is that it's open source
and we've actually seen this
experimentation play out
with anonymous teams forking
established projects the entire code
base the entire
model basically and siphoning off real
value real liquidity essentially
overnight has happened with summer
um with with uniswap and it's happening
with a couple you know
many other applications as well which is
why there's so many these also ran
tokens that i agree are garbage
but in theory um credible
uh anonymous developers which is not
an oxymoron necessarily um people have
actually proven their bona fides over
you know years of development in the
space that that are not actually known
entities
they could swoop in and basically offer
the same exact
protocols and maintain the same exact
protocols but just fork the economics
basically create a new system from
scratch and
with better privacy solutions also
coming online it becomes harder and
harder
to track that down and this gets into
this game of whack-a-mole
that ultimately can happen uh on a
global scale i tend to think that the
thing that works in the industry's favor
is that the powers of b are just going
to be so slow
in the west at least in the east totally
different story right if they can take
[ __ ] jack ma
off the street and say you really
shouldn't have said that at a conference
and by the way your ipo is canceled
like no one is untouchable over there
like just just point blank
like let's just get that out of the way
like at any point in time
china could become one of the biggest
players in bitcoin in crypto
or it could just be like a nuclear
threat to the entire industry for
a whole confluence of factors but when
when i think about like decentralization
crypto
and the regulatory sphere i'm primarily
thinking about the west and in the u.s
in europe um they're just not going to
be as fast
um or or is as well equipped to adapt
um and i have a heart too slow at the
game
i have a hot take on this they're going
to go the exact opposite direction
i think that the us is going to end up
being is going to end up embracing this
harder than anybody else
in the world i think i think in the next
10 presidential elections a bitcoiner
will become president
that's not somebody whose like entire
existence is around bitcoin but somebody
who
understands bitcoin believes in bitcoin
right there's congressman there's a
senator
now like there's people who are um
understanding
10 presidential elections 40 years
well yeah give yourself a little bit
more of a [ __ ] cushion pop come on
man
like 40 years like how long do you think
this is going to take to play out i
think we'll see it in that you know
within the next
four well it took 10 it took 10 years to
get uh get a congressman
right so like you know these
are exponential markets man like i i
agree it takes 40 years like we wasted
our lives
yeah well but here's the thing right is
like so i always
zoom out a little bit and i say okay
well how long would it take for let's
say bitcoin to become the global reserve
currency
like i actually think that it is uh a
multi-decade play now but that started
in 2009
right and so we're kind of 10 11 years
into this like there's a good chance
that there's another 10 or 20 years
before
you reach that now again you know bill
gates hey we overestimate what we can do
in one year underestimate what we can do
in ten
i would say most people didn't think
that we'd be sitting at twenty thousand
dollars ten eleven years after
uh bitcoin you know kind of uh went
public there
but at the same time when you start to
unpack some of this stuff like you know
take the d5 stuff
i don't think that there's very many
people who say hey we're not going to
get decentralized applications
all the controversy and debate is where
does it get built
right and where it gets built heavily
determines
the structure of how it gets built right
because most bitcoiners are like yeah of
course there's going to be decentralized
lending protocol
you know or decentralized lending
applications but it's going to get built
on the bitcoin protocol
right and some people disagree some
people agree whatever
but the structure in which that happens
if it happens will be very different
than if it gets built on another
platform
and i think that's the interesting part
here is as this stuff occurs
like do we end up in a world where you
know take the internet there's only four
or five protocols that
actually end up mattering do we end up
in a world where there's
a gazillion protocols that matter and
there's one that's
specific for certain countries or
regions or you know use cases or
whatever
or do we end up in one where the
strongest
most secure chain eats the world again
nobody knows right and i think that's
the part that like everyone has their
opinion
and i think a lot of people walk around
acting like uh there's facts right in
terms of this is what's going to happen
but i i don't know
right i don't think you're saying well
to take and
taken to the uh the extreme i mean we
don't need to get into too much of the
esoterica of you know
how these networks work but um
you know you're you're a believer that a
lot of this is going to get settled back
to bitcoin
um in fact one of my biggest regrets is
that i thought that for a long time
and that's one of the reasons i knew
about ethereum from the very earliest
stages
and i just couldn't wrap my head around
the token sale and and the mechanics of
that whole process
i actually don't believe that you're
gonna be shocked by that i actually
don't believe that
okay i i think i i think that bitcoin
ends up replicating most of it
what i think though is that most of
what's happening on let's say ethereum
take that as an example
is exactly what happened in 1996 to
2000.
all those ideas home runs a decade later
food delivery streaming music like
literally every single
idea that was tried then ended up not
succeeding
and it was people um over
or like short-term expectations
outran consumer behavior
right like people weren't ready for food
delivery [ __ ] people weren't ready for
food delivery
2019. right it took a pandemic and now
people are already like oh yeah
bring me my groceries and so i think the
same thing kind of happens
here where all these ideas end up
getting built for sure
but it's just you've got to allow the
network
to get built and you also have to allow
the behavior to change
and you can get retail people to go do
you know cdp's for example but like
that doesn't matter until you get like
big money to do it
right in in the grand scheme of like
global finance if you really want to
replace
kind of centralized entities that's who
you have to get but as we saw with
bitcoin like
that could take years to happen and so
it's like
are the teams that are building this now
going to be the ones that end up winning
or do they basically try all the right
ideas but then other teams build them
later
i don't know we're gonna find out but
like we've already seen technology
evolve that way in the past
so so i i think the two things that were
talking about though
are protocols versus teams right you
know like communities versus
versus you know centralized companies
yes the the 90s internet companies were
a decade early
but the internet protocols and and you
know
linux was was you know getting built out
then as well and that's
backbone for a lot of our modern you
know web so
um i i i think
one of the ways that you can tell most
of the experimentation
and most of the valuable protocol work
may happen on ethereum and these smart
contract platforms
versus bitcoin which is very rigidly
focused on peer-to-peer
payments and and settlement is that
bitcoin the asset is increasingly
getting
pegged uh to be traded on ethereum
through this concept of rap tokens and
and
these different interoperable uh
protocols that essentially allow you to
lock value in bitcoin lock a bitcoin
and then create a synthetic version of
it on ethereum or another blockchain
where it can actually be leveraged and
used in some type of application so
that's because it's not money though no
see but yes but i also wrote that right
so like i'm
we're we're on the same page there that
doesn't mean that a multi-trillion
dollar transaction processor
that's scaling exponentially is not
going to capture
insane economics yeah and there's not
going to be massive security spend to
actually
you know preserve the strength of that
network if you look at visa
right the mastercard is just the card
networks okay they do
they do one thing at scale incredibly
well
how many different applications are
going to come out like an internet of
money
that's the orders of magnitude larger
that ethereum or
the winning smart contract protocols are
going to be and i just
you know the i just don't see the mind
share
there in bitcoin to make that particular
platform
that extensible that doesn't mean that
bitcoin
may not win the race in terms of uh
in terms of value creation but this is
why i think about if you're going to
have exposure to this industry you want
exposure to crypto
and the defense defy you know boom
even as early as it is and then you also
want exposure obviously to the winning
you know decentralized money
um and i i truly think that we're
talking about two different
industries almost at this point when
people think about getting exposure to
crypto
have to have a little bit of both all
right but you can wait
and i think that you have time but why
wouldn't you click the premium
in the meantime if you can let me yes
last question on uh on
ether uh do you look at bitcoin being
back to
all-time high levels and ether i think
it's still down like 50 plus percent
right it didn't go i think it hit 1400
in
2017. i remember correctly yes it's like
around 600.
yeah well i wrote about this in the
ethos not money section right you know
the
i think that was an anomaly in bitcoin's
history because there's a few things
happening at the same time
um maybe most importantly bitcoin
was in the midst of its most contentious
community issue that forked the network
and
it was unclear for a few months
which direction things were going to go
in terms of which chain was going to win
out
which way the the community was
ultimately going to shift
the winning side ended up being the side
that was
ostensibly the minority fork that was
not necessarily supported by almost all
of the largest investors largest miners
and and largest
you know funded infrastructure companies
in the industry um
which is what made it such a wild time
of course you know the spike in in
bitcoin's price in the all-time high
happened after that issue was
finally put to bed and resolved um but
2017
while that was going on for bitcoin was
also the year that
the ico boom occurred and at that point
ether wasn't money still
but it was serving as the reserve of
that ecosystem and you had to hold
ether in order to fund these icos now
with the explosion of stable coins
you know across uh across the industry
and this is true for bitcoin and
ethereum
it's less critical to actually hold an
unstable reserve asset as we saw in the
early days
so um i don't think it's surprising or
nor do i think it's an indictment of
ethereum
that it's it's still 50 percent of its
peak
the way that i look at it is it's it's
maybe sustainably at a sixth
of bitcoins market cap um and exactly
where that right you know dividing line
is i i don't know but
i would uh i would certainly buy ether
when it's below 10 of bitcoin's market
cap and maybe sell it when it gets above
50
where the dividing line is anywhere in
between um
is uh is is anybody's gas i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna
my crystal ball is broken man i'm
exhausted
are you a flipping believer of the
market caps
no i i uh i think if that happens
first of all that happens anytime soon
we can [ __ ] pack our toys and go home
because it like it ruins bitcoin's
narrative i think it hurts that they're
in because ethereum's not ready for
prime time yet that type of
you know like sovereign attention um
because the protocol itself is still not
you know ossified or battle tested
particularly with this migration to um
to basically an entirely new
system um but i think
uh at some point you know could eth be
money
is is really the question i think if
bitcoin loses fundability basically if
there's top-down uh regulatory
crackdowns that essentially create a
bifurcated bitcoin system between clean
coins and dirty coins that would be one
attack vector
um there are you know geopolitical risks
around
concentration of of mining right but
if if china and western states you know
kind of came together and said you know
we're basically going to disallow this
type of
activity for whatever reasons i think it
has a much worse impact than anybody
gives it credit for uh i know it's more
or less dismissed as fud
uh from from the bitcoin community i
don't think it is if it were like a true
global coordinated crackdown on on
hashing and bitcoin mining uh per se
uh and then the last thing and maybe the
most likely is we we will not know for a
few more years
how well bitcoin security model holds up
when the uh
rate of senior edge uh basically you
know annual network issuance of new
bitcoin um
dips down below one percent and then
half a percent and ethereum has to solve
that problem so
um there may still be time right and
and ethereum may get less risky over the
course the next few years
as bitcoin gets potentially more risky
depending on how things play out on that
last front with um
the fees to actually secure the network
but you know
there's a lot that's going to happen
between now and then so i mean it's like
almost not even worth talking about
normally i just kind of like you know
uh i give hot takes on this and i
immediately say
literally everything i'm saying means
absolutely nothing
because there are so many there's so
many more
massively important things that are
going to happen in the interim that we
have no idea how it's going to play out
i love it uh the final boss is
the final thing i want to talk about
let's do it
what is the final boss and uh talk me
through kind of your theory here
every time that bitcoin
doesn't die it gets stronger right just
this like
naseem tele concept of anti-fragility
and
it it just won't die
and it gets stronger every single year
from a combination of more people
believing in it more people using it
more infrastructure being built around
it hardening of the code base
and uh i truly think that the only uh
real threat at this point to bitcoin is
going to come from sovereigns right so
this would be a combination
of regulatory crackdowns um
and potential just outright bands um
and that can come uh a few different
ways you can
make it harder for anyone that's
actually using bitcoin and and
transacting the economy
to get banking um you can
essentially make it insanely expensive
from a compliance standpoint
if not possible from a compliance
standpoint to actually
satisfy regulator demands for um
what they want to see in order to you
know support any
uh transactions that go through the
bitcoin network
um and you know we could see
uh as bitcoin and
related applications get more private
right if we do go from
pseudonymous but still traceable
transaction
sets through these uh forensics
companies like chanalysis and elliptic
and the one
basically the ones that work with the
governments and the big compliance teams
worldwide um if um if there are
solutions that basically break
the utility of those forensic tools
um then you've got a big problem and and
i think you know you can you can see
what we've started to see glimpses of
which is the doj you know ccp other kind
of global regulators
saying we're not sure how we feel about
self-custody
because it's kind of like a swiss bank
account in your pocket and we're sure
we're sure not not sure how we feel
about
privacy uh like blanket you know
anonymity
solutions things like uh what z cash is
introduced
basically making it next to impossible
to actually trace you know
pseudonymously or otherwise
any transactions that happen on the
network and there's good reason for that
right that's not
um uh there there needs to be some type
of balance and the good news is in most
cases
the folks that have built these you know
tools have thought about that
and they've been mindful of that
challenge and and the fact that you're
always going to
um you're going to need to help the
regulated edges of the network right the
interfaces on and off of
these these protocols um
you're going to need to give them the
tools to actually interface with the
powers that they
uh and you know catch bad guys and and
you know
make sure that there's not systemic risk
in these systems and things like that
so um you know you're talking about
we're
at half of half a trillion dollars now
in global market cap
uh almost 400 now for for bitcoin
so uh 400 billion now um
that's uh that's no longer you know
below the radar
uh by any stretch and you know i i think
that we'll see over a hundred thousand
dollar bitcoin
uh by the end of next year i don't know
if that's that's
on par with you or if you're even if
you're even higher than that
i think i think we're i think you and i
are both you know uh
like insanely bullish by traditional
standards but maybe
you know not as shrill as some of the
other folks that are just trying to get
like the biggest number of posts in the
wall street journal
um but i do think we'll see a hundred
thousand dollar bitcoin and so
at that point um you know we're we're
well over trillion dollars
um in market value and the liquidity in
that network is insane
so you can move a lot of money um if
you're uh if you're a bad actor
we're a good actor um and that's that's
got it's it's regulatory challenges and
we got to figure out exactly how it's
going to work
so uh final boss i am betting
on bitcoin and good guys and the wild
western
um for no other reason i just think the
west is completely dysfunctional and
it's going to take them forever to fully
wrap their their heads around it
yeah i i also think uh there's this
weird undertone
of uh why don't we embrace it um
and i it sounds crazy right now cause i
agree with you like there's a lot of uh
disjointness but when you see brian
brooks you know
hey you guys can custody this no one's
gonna ban it kind of a lot of stuff
going on like that
you really only need you know four or
five more people
uh in positions of uh influence and
power i think to uh
to kind of say hey maybe we should take
this much more seriously and not as a
threat but instead of
as a uh almost as parachute to some
degree
and unfortunately unfortunately brian
might have like four
four more weeks left of the job because
you know uh you have to
you know everything that can be
politicized will be politicized in the
in the us
uh realm and i unfortunately have the
feeling
that um the the democratic party
is going to be more hostile to this
industry than the republicans
um so you know we'll see how
that ultimately plays out but we gotta
we gotta get more blue
uh more blue reps on on on team orange
if uh if we're gonna actually have a
good time next year
sam bankman freed is uh you know he's
gonna buy his way into the white house
at
the rate he's going so you know what
he's at least going to get a meeting
with someone in the administration
that's a good thing for everybody
absolutely all right where can we send
people to download the report
find you on the internet and find out
more about what you guys are building
sure uh missouri.io we've got a brand
spanking new homepage
that was basically 10 feature releases
rolling into one that
actually just dropped last week as well
so it's been a big big december for us
it's a beautiful interface to catch up
on on news
uh basic uh price information bisector
um uh charting tools it's really become
my second screen i think a lot of others
you know really quickly
um to get a full soup to nuts overview
of
uh how the market's performing
day-to-day you will see a link
uh to the report crypto theses for 2021
front center right on right on that
homepage
for probably the next month or so
because this will be the largest report
that we have out
at least through january as you can
imagine so i encourage people to go
there
check out the report and then sign up
for our
daily newsletter as well if you're
interested
in getting more than just orange coin
information from pomp
and and you want to actually take the uh
take the the purple pill
um that will get you excited for
i'm just going to try to layer the
innuendo on because we're recording late
on a sunday night
i uh i i write about the other stuff i
just write about it when there's rug
pulls and all the other nonsense
oh man you know what you said you you
sound like the
bitcoiners version of peter schiff now
don't don't don't don't do that
don't do that again the mind pump again
listen like i always say i've invested
in uh
more companies than most of the trolls
on twitter that are building on top of
this other stuff
i'm not by any means uh not
open-minded it's just i'm a i'm a
rationalist
right in terms of uh nobody nobody likes
to call out the uh
the nonsense you can be successful and
you can have a successful
piece of technology or community and
still say hey 80
of this stuff's nonsense but the one
thing i will say uh
outside of a select few people who
um i'll call them like uh the eath heads
and that'll set them all off but there's
a there's a couple
outside of that group um i actually find
that
a lot of the developers and people who
are building in the space
uh are very very open-minded one and two
also very rational
and if i ask them you know hey the d5
applications like what percentage of
them are actually decentralized
but the answer they say would shock most
people
because you would think that they would
just kind of be blind to everything and
just say like oh 100
that's not the answer like they actually
answer honestly and and very open-minded
and then they lay out an argument for
like and here's how we get from i don't
know
20 percent of all being decentralized to
80 of them right and so
i i i actually really enjoy talking to a
lot of those people
um and uh you know maybe we'll keep
investing a little bit more
bitcoin was centralized on halloween
2008. it's come a long way since then so
is the rest of crypto
but uh yeah we'll we'll see what happens
next year uh
and in the meantime i am happy to
continue going back and forth with you
on twitter i am at two bit idiots
uh pomp leapfrogged me by i think uh an
order of magnitude almost uh since our
last conversation a couple years ago so
i got up my game in the new year but
you know what if uh if crypto takes off
and you're wrong about defy
i'm i'll be right on your nipping at
your heels baby
[Laughter]
we will see we will see all right my
friend listen thank you so much for
doing
this i'll do it again in the future
absolutely thank you pomp